hey what is up everybody it's animak
here for anime out pro
and today i will be discussing the most
recent events
in the boku no hero story including the
dark
origins of one for all and that
mysterious vestige world which contains
the consciousnesses
of previous one for all users we finally
got some important
answers to some of the biggest mysteries
in
this series and the real final battle of
this arc has just been set up so let's
get
into it if you enjoy our boku no hero
content and you want us to keep it going
please leave a like to let me know
it really does help and if you're new to
anime pro
or you just haven't subscribed make this
the video do you subscribe and
hit that notification bell to turn on
all notifications
by the way we've started live reacting
to the latest leaks and spoilers for
boku no hero and other series
over on our twitch channel if you'd like
to chat with us about the latest reveals
before we even publish
our videos here on the youtube channel
follow us on twitch
right now twitch.tv slash anime uproar
or click the top link down in the
description
and of course this video will contain
boku no hero manga spoilers proceed with
caution all that good stuff now let's
get into it if you've seen my previous
boku no hero video then you know that
the last installment of the story
left me with many many questions
what is this so-called vestige world and
how are deku
shigaraki nana and all for one all able
to exist
together inside this strange
non-physical world
in the newest installment of the story
we definitely got some answers including
some jaw-dropping secrets about one for
all
and all for one but even so there are
still many lingering mysteries that are
yet to be resolved the latest chapter
starts off with nana
making her presence known to all for one
inside the vestige world
to me it seems like nana is being
protective of deku
and she seems to be challenging all for
one in order to stop him from attacking
deku and stealing one for all
all for one laughs at the fact that a
corpse is talking to him
he mocks nana right in front of
shigaraki and he even tells shigaraki
outright that this is his grandmother
all for one doesn't seem to be hiding
the truth from shigaraki at all
he doesn't feel the need to hide the
fact that he was the one who murdered
his grandmother
deku concludes that all of this must be
happening inside of one for all itself
so that means that shigaraki and all for
one have managed to gain entry
into the vestige world that was supposed
to be a place that only one for all's
users
are able to enter this is no joke if
they've made it this far
then all for one and shigaraki could
potentially steal
one for all this is serious and deku
knows it
but how were the villains able to
infiltrate this mysterious non-physical
world
that was supposed to be exclusive to the
users of one for all
that was my biggest question in the
previous video and thankfully in this
chapter
all for one finally gives us some
answers all for one explains that just
like some people claim to take on the
personality traits of their donors
following an
organ transplant all for one experienced
a similar phenomenon every time he stole
someone's quirk he would experience
vivid dreams and memories that didn't
seem to be his own
rather they seemed to belong to the
original owners of the quirks that he
had stolen
at first all for one thought that maybe
this was like his own guilty conscience
playing tricks on him
but then he noticed that whenever he
would relinquish a quirk that he had
stolen
he would instantly stop experiencing the
strange thoughts and dreams of the
original user
once he met ujico all for one understood
what was really happening
all quirks seem to hold the memories and
personality traits
of their original users and these traits
remain
even once the quirk is transferred to
someone else
essentially once all for one steals
someone's quirk
a portion of their personality some
aspect of their consciousness
is still embedded inside the quirk
factor
all for one always thought that the
ability to interact with the
consciousnesses of the people whose
quirks he had stolen was a phenomenon
that was exclusive to him
but he now realizes that some form of
this phenomenon had also manifested
within
one for all as a result some aspect of
each former user's consciousness has
embedded itself
within the one for all quirk factor and
that is what allows nana and the other
former users to interact with deku
inside the vestige world that is also
what allows them to influence deku's
behavior at times
like when they helped him break the
effects of shinto's quirk all those
chapters ago
it seems to me that when all for one
created the quirk one for all by
combining his brother's original quirk
with the stockpiling quirk
all for one itself created the vestige
world
this phenomenon is no longer unique to
all for one
because his own quirk was used to create
one for all so this ability to interact
with the consciousnesses of former users
became something that every user of one
for all could also
do all for one believes this to be a
curse because while he can simply get
rid of the quirks that he has stolen
and that allows him to get rid of the
original owner's consciousness
users of one for all don't have the
ability to relinquish the quirk factors
of former users
as a result all for one's brother and
all the other former users of one for
all
are basically stuck inside of one for
all for
all eternity a fragment of their
consciousness
is forever trapped within this dark
vestige world
and to all for one this is more of a
curse than a blessing
as all for one is speaking shigeraki and
nana recognize each other
shigaraki never knew nana but he
recognized her from his father's photo
and far from feeling compassion for his
grandmother shigaraki makes it clear
that along with his father
he also blames her for all of his
suffering
even though he never met nana shigaraki
blames her for setting everything that
happened to him
in motion when she abandoned her family
and so shigaraki along with all for one
attacks nana and deku and deku can
feel that one for all is being eroded by
this attack
one for all appears to be in real danger
of being stolen
and whether the villains can actually
steal it or not will depend on this
battle of wills which is now taking
place inside the strange
vestige world all for one encourages
shigaraki to keep
going the quirk all for one is
responding to shigaraki's unquenchable
rage and presumably if shigaraki's rage
and willpower is strong enough
he will be able to steal one for all
we've always been told that one for all
needs to be given up
voluntarily but all for one is the quirk
stealing quirk
and all for one is the quirk that
literally created one for all
all for one himself clearly believes
that stealing one for all is possible
so i do think that it might be otherwise
all for one spent
decades trying to do this even though it
was impossible
and that would be kind of anticlimactic
and it doesn't seem that all for one
would be
that gullible one interesting thing that
i have to point out is the fact that
shigaraki not only hates nana and deku
but all for one notices that chikaraki
detests him
as well probably because of one is
trying to manipulate him from inside his
own body and shigaraki isn't having
any of it at this point shigaraki really
does hate everyone
and he is ready to go all out until the
bitter end he has nothing to lose
far from being upset that shigaraki
hates him all for one thinks that this
is brilliant
he believes that this hateful mindset is
exactly what shigaraki needs to become
the greatest villain
the symbol of fear but it is clear to
all for one that
something isn't working shigaraki hasn't
been able to overcome and absorb
one for all and that is because the
original one for all user
all for one's brother can be just as
stubborn as he
is at this point we see all for one's
brother appear next to nana
and he proclaims that they will not
relinquish the power of all for one
over to the villains the former one for
all users have chosen to stay inside
deku
and they will lend deku their strength
and the power of their wills so that he
can beat shigaraki
back this appears to work and shigaraki
feels himself being pushed back by one
for all
and the collective willpower of deku and
the former users
all for one implores shigaraki to let
him take over and land his own strength
to shigarakis
as he does this all for one does his
best to provoke
deku apparently offer one has been
watching deku through shigaraki for some
time
and he has learned a lot of deku's
weaknesses so all for one starts calling
deku useless he says that deku couldn't
even protect his own friends and
teachers
he is so weak that he can't even move
his own body inside the vestige world
and so on
i believe that these provocations are
specifically designed to rattle deku and
to
lower his willpower so that shiguraki
could overpower him and steal
one for all unfortunately for the
villains this strategy does not work
the original one for all user explains
that deku is someone who always does his
best for
others not himself he is someone who is
prepared to sacrifice everything for
others and he's not interested in his
own
personal gain as a result deku uses this
urge to save others
as his willpower and this allows him to
overcome all
challenges including common sense itself
that is a good point
actually because for better or worse
deku often does things that defy
common sense in that moment deku is
somehow able to move his body
and he surges forward right at shigaraki
the next thing we see both shigaraki and
deku are ejected from the vestige world
and they are back
in the real world floating in the air
they both appear to be severely injured
but shigaraki seems to be in a much
worse state than deku shigeru hears the
voice of all for one yet again
and also one explains that shigaraki's
body is too weak to overwhelm one for
all
because his procedure was interrupted
prematurely all for one tells him to
step
back and replenish his energy at least
for now and deku hopes that shigaraki
will give
up and stop fighting in spite of
everything that happened
deku still doesn't want to kill
shigaraki he is hesitating to deal the
final blow
and it's safe to assume that deku will
come to regret this
eventually i mean once giganto makia and
the others show up
the heroes will have their plates full
and shigaraki will have time to
recuperate
so by not killing shigaraki right now
deku is likely putting himself
and his friends and the wider hero
society in imminent danger
at some point in the future the chapter
then switches focus back to
gigantomachia and the other villains
they must be close to the jakku
battlefield because dabi is excited that
both shigaraki and endeavor
are in the same place dobby believes
that they are about to liberate the hero
society
once and for all and i honestly can't
wait for dobby
shoto and endeavor to all meet in the
same place
meanwhile toga is still clearly
traumatized by twice's death at the
hands of the heroes
toga asks mr compress if heroes are
supposed to save people
then was twice not a person in their
eyes
why did they kill him instead of saving
him and are they going to kill her
too toga says that she wants to ask that
question to deku and ochako
and it seems that toga's actions will be
guided by the answer that they give
toga is crazy so you never know what
she's thinking but presumably
if they say that twice deserved to die
then toga would attack them
but i doubt they wouldn't even say
anything like that even about a villain
but we'll wait and see
personally i think toga's comparison
here is totally off base
i mean i know that she's crazy and a
villain so her perspective is skewed
but it's not like twice was just like a
troubled guy who was minding his own
business and then hawks killed him
twice in the other villains are
responsible for the deaths of many
people
and they are planning to wage a war
against the hero society
a war that will definitely have a lot of
civilian collateral damage
i mean just look at what is happening
right now with maki as rampage
and twice's sad man's parade is an
ability whose destructive potential is
on par with machias
hawks tried to talk twice into giving
himself up peacefully
but when that failed and twice was about
to get away hawks had to kill him to
stop twice from using his quirk to kill
countless
others including pro-heroes and
potentially even innocent civilians
don't get me wrong i liked twice as a
character he was a fascinating and
nuanced villain
and his death was definitely sad but
from hawks's perspective
he did what he had to do by killing
twice even though he didn't want to do
it
he likely saved many lives so hawks did
what he had to do
i know toga is upset because twice was
her friend but hey you know you're a
villain
right and you know that you're fighting
in a war that you yourself
wanted to start against the entire
society i mean
actions like that have consequences
villains do bad things and they hurt a
lot of people and heroes have to stop
them deku's hesitation and taking
shigaraki out
could come back to haunt him i mean i'm
sure it will
and that is why i do believe that hawks
did the right thing even though it was a
difficult and tragic thing to do
but let me know what you guys think what
is going to happen next
i'm thinking that deku will refuse to
kill shigaraki and this will give
shigaki time to recuperate once the
other villains arrive
and the heroes are too busy dealing with
them i also predict that dobby is
finally going to reveal his identity
once he comes face to face with shoto
and endeavor let me know if you agree
and what did you think about this epic
clash between one for all
and all for one did it surprise you to
learn that the vestige world was likely
a creation of all for one itself
and do you believe that one for all can
really be stolen
by all for one definitely share your
thoughts down in the comments below
if you enjoyed this video show your love
by leaving a like
it really means a lot and if you're new
to anime uproar or you just haven't
subscribed
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on
all notifications you really have to go
through the trouble of hitting that bell
and then selecting the option that says
all
if you don't do that you're still going
to miss a ton of our videos even if you
are subscribed
it's just how youtube works don't forget
to follow us on twitch twitch.tv slash
animeopro
for all the latest leaks spoilers and
breakdowns for boku no hero
and other series i want to give a big
thank you to all of our
anime uproar patrons for making videos
like this one possible
a special thank you to alpha sigma and
liam thompson
disciples of lord twigo himself
and i can't forget all of our the one
tier patrons
the ones who rise above all other clans
including
ingrata the world acquired respect pate
heffa
jonathan king rathune de ora emperor
otaku
thomas jones kin mano admirath and chris
torley
finally thank you also to our pro hero
tier patrons
including the one and only gilgamesh
nothing but a fan
king zeldris anatoly kazatsky angel cruz
cricket xp joe stanton very gucci alicia
ochter hinokami and water
bonnie parks jason wilson florian joy
and garcia
steelers mcshamus jessica calefon deadly
saint
stearnhawkings and highschooldxd73
if you enjoy our videos and you feel
that they provide value to you
consider becoming a patron even a single
dollar will give you access to our
patron exclusive discord
and your name will appear in our videos
along with these
amazing people as always thank you guys
so much for watching
and until next time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you